now one of our first things that was
really controversial was oreo first
chips ahoy wait what
who takes chips ahoy over oreo thank you
sir what are you saying mark aye chip's
ahoy oh you're insane i'm team chips
ahoy all the way you're insane and i'm
all day what are you guys oreo oreo
orange challenge the game yeah dude
chips ahoy has fallen off hard i feel
the quality of a chips ahoy has fallen
off i haven't had it they're smaller
there's less chips they're cooked they
taste like chemicals now look how many
jobs oreo has given to people we've got
the lemon cream we've got the the golden
oreos [ __ ] good dude oreo's in
everything popping on ice cream i just
you can't beat a chocolate chip oreo is
a classic dude well it wasn't chocolate
chip it's not chocolate chips you want
to be clear that it's not it doesn't
mean chocolate chip cookie a great
chocolate chip cookie no one's denying
the power i got another controversial
take oatmeal raisin love mmm i like
oatmeal really good
good oatmeal raisin cookie is outrageous
outrageous outrageous